You don't have to believe in it.
There's no dogma,
you know,
even like I said,
it uses iconography and symbolism from,
you know,
things like gnostic Christianity and
Esoteric Judaism,
things like that,
but it doesn't require you to believe in
these things.
The reason that uses a symbolism is,
you know,
for example,
in the part of the country that I grew
up in,
there are literally places where you
come to a four way stop and there are
churches on all four corners,
so even if you're completely atheist,
even if you're repelled by these things,
they are still part of your psyche still
part of our,
our culture.
So we on some level respond to those
things in some way.
That doesn't mean we necessarily have to
believe in them for Magic to work.
You know,
like I said,
the people who devise these techniques
wanted to know what works,
why it works,
how it works,
and how we can make it work better.
You don't have to believe in any of this
any more than you have to believe that
your muscles are going to get bigger by
going to the gym.
I'll hear a lot of people say,
you know,
I don't believe in magic,
and I'll think,
well actually what you mean is you've
never tried magic because it doesn't
require belief.
If you hadn't actually tried these
things,
you know,
invested time and energy into attempting
to do them,
you would see that they actually did
work.
That it's not a a process of belief.
The way that.
I guess one of the things that was so
hard about eastern traditions like zen
was you focus almost entirely on staying
in the present moment all the time.
You know,
that is really,
really hard once you actually start
trying to do that.
You realize how out of control your
thoughts are.
You know,
our thoughts chase themselves around
like a dog chasing its own tail all the
time from the time we get up until the
time we go to sleep and a lot of the
eastern traditions deal with almost
wrestling against that.
You know,
every time you realize you're doing it,
bringing yourself back to the present
moment,
back to the present moment over and over
and over.
For me,
I didn't get a lot of results out of
that,
you know,
I never found myself in the present
moment more than I was whenever I
started the practices ceremonial magic.
On the other hand,
what it does is it doesn't really
address that at all.
Instead you're dealing like for example,
on energy circulation practices where
you're circulating ci through different
parts of your body.
You're trying to energize different
energy centers that run down through
your spine.
Doing that as a side effect.
You become more and more present and I
didn't even realize you know the.
A lot of these practices say for
example,
the lesser banishing ritual of the
Pentagram.
When you would learn these things,
traditionally the organization,
the order would give you these exercises
and they would not tell you what they're
going to do.
They would not tell you what they're
for.
They would say,
go practice this for a year.
Come back and talk to us then,
and if you're interested in learning
more and going forward,
we'll talk about it.
Then whenever you came back they would
say,
okay,
well what did you experience?
That's how they would know if you had
actually been practicing them or not.
So I would these techniques,
the middle pillar,
the lesser banishing ritual of the
Pentagram.
And one day while I was in prison,
I bent over to tie my shoes and I
realized without even trying to do so,
I was in the present moment and it was
almost like an atomic bomb going off
because it was for the very first time
in my life I realized,
Oh my God,
I'm completely in the present moment.
Of course,
the second you think that it shattered
and you know,
you're back to thinking or whatever.
But it was even after years of zen
practice,
it was the first time that I truly
experienced that and it was due to
ceremonial magic.
So one of the techniques that I use,
uh,
you know,
the analogy I used earlier about
flushing yourself out like a cup of
water.
This is a technique that flushes our
thoughts out.
You know,
if you have a song going through your
head over and over,
or if you're reliving an argument you
had with someone a year ago,
if you're obsessed over something that
you can't get out of your head,
this technique is good for that as well
as just general meditation purposes.
It doesn't have a name.
I usually just refer to it as the prison
cell meditation.
Um,
but if you're interested,
I'll do that.
Is that okay?
All right.
You start by closing your eyes
and then you envision yourself in a
prison sale.
Standing in the center of a sale.
Everything is white.
The walls are white,
ceiling is white.
The floors are white.
The only thing there is in the sale
other than you on the back wall is a
slit of a window and it's up so high
that the only way that you can reach it,
the only way you can see out of it is by
gripping the window ledge,
high above your head and hoisting
yourself up by sheer brute physical,
upper body strength.
Almost like you're doing a pull up or a
chin up.
So you want to bring as much tactile
sensation to the visualization as you
possibly can.
You want to feel it as much as you can.
So picture yourself walking to the back
of this wall,
pressing yourself against it,
reaching up with your hands and gripping
the edge of that window.
Seal with your fingertips.
Try to feel what the back wall of that
prison cell would feel like pressed
against the side of your face,
pressed against your torso.
Feel the coldness of it,
the grittiness of it,
and as you start to lift yourself up off
the floor using gesture arms,
try to feel what that would actually
feel like.
Feel the muscles in your shoulders.
Feel the muscles in your chest and your
abdomen firing,
tensing.
As you're pulling yourself up,
try to feel what the wall would feel
like as you scrape against it.
Lifting yourself slowly by shear
strength
as your eyes crest over the rim of the
window,
white light burst through the window,
floods through the window,
and obliterates everything.
The sale you everything until there's
only white light remaining.
Do it again.
Press yourself against the back of the
wall.
Reach out with both hands and gripped
the edge of the window sill.
Feel the muscles in your chest and your
abdomen and your shoulders tensing.
As you start to lift yourself up,
feel the wall scrape against the front
of your thighs against the side of your
face.
As you hoist yourself,
until your eyes go over the edge of the
window frame and then white light comes
flooding in through the window,
obliterating everything you the sale
until there's only white light.
Once more,
feel yourself pressed against the wall.
Raise your arms,
Hook your fingertips over the window
ledge.
Begin to raise yourself slowly up by
sheer strength,
feeling the muscles in your shoulders,
your chest,
your torso,
straining as you lift your body weight.
Feel the wall of the prison sale as you
scrub against it,
and as your eyes go over the edge of the
window frame,
white light comes flooding in,
obliterating everything,
and this is one of those things you can
do for as long as you have time.
You can do it five times,
you can do it 10 times.
The longer you do it,
the more effective it is.
And it gives you something to work with,
you know,
in your visualization,
instead of just trying to stay in the
present moment,
which is really,
really hard.